I hope it,
I hope it comes out,
um,
intensely.
Um,
that's not to say that it's about me,
that I,
I think that,
you know,
conducting is obviously a visual
activity because it's about showing
things with your gesture to the
musicians.
But I don't want the audience to feel
that they have to see a show from me in
order to,
to feel how exciting that the music is.
Um,
but on the other hand,
if the music is exciting and if I look
unengaged and not not in it,
then that would certainly prevent the
experience from being what it really
should be.
So it's a fine line that you have to
sort of walk to,
to really infuse the performance and the
music with your deeply committed
personality while allowing the music to
still be paramount.
It's a,
it's a tricky thing and that's,
uh,
that's what we're all all going for.
Absolutely.
I mean,
I,
you know,
you have to allow your face to show the
show the character of the music.
But that's not something that I plan,
you know,
it's like you don't say,
okay,
well I want them to think I'm happy so
I'll smile now.
Um,
you're naturally allow yourself to feel
the music and then just as you,
you know,
when you're hanging out,
sometimes your face looks more serious.
Sometimes it looks more animated,
sometimes it looks more pensive.
You,
no,
that's definitely part of the
communication.
It happens right away actually are.
Hopefully it does.
If it doesn't,
then there's probably something wrong.
Um,
it's interesting.
You can,
you can,
you can really understand the difference
in orchestra,
um,
feels and conductors,
if you go to a conducting class where
there may be six or 10 or 12 conductors
in a very short span of time,
often it happens that these conductors
will be doing the same music.
So you have a really good basis of
comparison.
The sound is literally different within
one second of instantly,
once a new conductor comes on,
they'll conduct the same music that had
just been done by another conductor.
The orchestra sounds completely
different.
It's uncanny.
There's something in the body language
that immediately translates into sound.
And,
uh,
that's one of the exciting and kind of,
amazing things about conducting.